у мене іноді складається враження
що всі ці законопроекти спеціально
спрямовані на те щоб як найбільше
розізлити українців роздратувати їх
налякати але по серйозному із держави в
держава не хоче говорити зз громадянами
по-людськи по-нормальному Просто
пояснити що і для чого робиться я вже не
кажу про повагу до опози
фракцій які
отримають таблицю про друге читання в
останній момент але за нами теж стоять
люди виборці які теж треба потребують
поваги але те що сьогодні
робиться цим законопроектом
Це не про
полегшення надання статусу учаснико
бойових дій це про великого брата із
оруелівського твору
984 це про стеження за всіма українцями
це про збір понаднормової інформації про
всіх українців про всіх чоловіків які
які підлягають
мобілізації у мене іноді просто
складається враження що Ну давайте ще
запишемо в цей законопроект кожному на
лоба
привісити веб-камеру і ходити з нею
постійно от тоді він буде повністю
відповідати антиутопії оруела Але чи ми
будуємо демократичне суспільство чи ми
будуємо
авторитарну Утопію яка була написана для
того щоб налякати людей і ніколи в житті
не підійти до такого Ви зараз же лякаєте
людей таким
майбутнім Я абсолютно переконаний що цей
законопроект в такому вигляді приймати
ні в якому разі не можна Я розумію що
тут абсолютно всім що я говорю і
що говорять Мої колеги даруйте на слові
тому що кожен займається в залі своїми
справами Голова Верховної Ради тре про
щось кожен Більшість депутатів сидить в
мобільних телефонах або там як як на
тусовках на світських раутах між собою
розмовляють але ми говоримо зараз про
долі людей яких мають яких мають
залучати мобілізовувати в
майбутньому мобілізовувати до захисту
країни і їх треба не як в Радянському
Союзі зганяти як скот а з людьми в
демократичній і вільній країні треба
поводитися відпові відповідно до всіх
світових нормальних вимог те що ми зараз
робимо буде мати дуже погані наслідки і
в тому числі і на мобілізацію тому що
системно лякати людей це означатиме
настроювати їх проти держави а це
злочин